[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Ani and I'm an
interdisciplinary artist
practicing at the intersection
of art and science.
I say interdisciplinary
because the mediums of my work
range from custom
designed circuits
that mediate your vision,
to the chemical synthesis
of a perfume that smells
like a particular human,
to biologically engineered
apparatuses that
control the movement of sperm.
I would say that I'm a
research-based artist,
and like many
scientists and artists,
I make work to
understand the world.
At the root of my work,
I think I'm constantly
trying to ask, how do
scientific theories inform
culture, subjectivity, and
what it means to be human?
Hi, my name is Angel.
I'm a graduating student in
the program for Art, Culture
and Technology.
My work at MIT has
been about looking
at science and technology
from the point-of-view
of a critical art
practice, asking
questions of what it produces
beyond practical empirical
knowledge.
And so my projects have engaged
with the mindsets, the space,
the images, and the materiality
that the science and technology
infrastructure produces.
Hello.
My name is Jessica
Sarah Rinland.
My work investigates and unifies
opposing themes, interweaving
original and found
material, highlighting
the incongruity of
factual accounts.
My core interest lies in the
fluctuation of knowledge,
how facts, and the way
they are disseminated,
develop and change
over time, and how
this affects
human's relationship
with and within nature.